for months President Trump has been
calling for a crackdown on leaks of
classified information now for the first
time since mr. Trump took office and
alleged leaker faces criminal charges
the Justice Department says reality ly
winner confessed to giving a top-secret
report to a news website when it faces
charges under the Espionage Act the
president complained in February that
the FBI could not stop what he called
lowlife leakers he demanded action again
one month later and he repeated in may
find the leakers about one hour before a
reality ly winner was charged a leaked
NSA report was revealed online and it
suggests that Russian intelligence tried
to break into u.s. electronic voting
systems just days before the November
election
the intercept posted the classified
documents CBS News has confirmed the
report is legitimate Jeffrey gazes in
Washington with the details from those
documents but we begin with Jan Crawford
and the charges against the young woman
accused of the leaking Jan good morning
good morning winter was arrested
Saturday and Augusta Georgia 25 years
old she held a top-secret security
clearance at a government facility where
she worked as a contractor with pluribus
international corporation now the
Justice Department alleges that winter
printed out the classified document
which was dated May 5th and that she
admitted to removing retaining and
mailing it the government also says it
found evidence that winter had email
contact with the news outlet from her
work computer now President Trump has
called for a crackdown on leaks he
slammed the FBI on Twitter in late
February saying leaks could have a
devastating effect but this isn't the
first White House to crack down remember
the Obama administration brought at
least eight leak related prosecutions
over eight years now winter remains in
federal custody and she'll have a
detention hearing on Thursday if
convicted she could pace up to ten years
in prison
we reached out to a pluribus
international for comment but we've not
heard back charlie thanks Jen